hot breath but you're around the good
audiences but you're also around
like amazing comedians what have you
learned from working with that level of
talent
you learn a lot from mattel because he's
such a he's such a
uh he can't like he must just never stop
thinking of
jokes he's just always in joke for him
which is like can't be the best
existence ever but it makes for
a damn good comment it's making my way
such a pure comedian yeah
you learn you learn a little from
everyone like i've learned a lot from
amy i've learned a lot from
you know she produced my special so she
helped me put it together and
uh edit and uh
so yeah you learn how to
how to really you learn different skills
from different people you know she
she was performing in you know arenas
when i was opening for her so
i learned how to really kind of hold
punch lines a little longer and how to
i i'd watch how she kind of conducted
herself and it's so yeah i mean as we
were saying like you perform in a big
venue one night
i mean i think i was opening for one
night in the venue for like 14
000 people the next time i was in the
village for like 12 people and you're
like well that's how it goes you know
that's
yeah yeah that's how that's probably how
it'll always be hmm
there's some comfort to that right where
you're like well it'll always be that
inconsistent at least it'll always be
that mercurial lifestyle yeah i used to
spark anymore yeah i feel like a lot of
comics started doing i did that for a
long time
uh and that's yeah that sucks
no one wants to hand out flyers but it
makes you it makes it a little sweeter
when uh when you see those guys out
there
barking you're like well you know i used
to do that
and they and you know some of them
you've seen for years you're like we
should probably quit if you're still
doing like i've been parking for years
yeah i've definitely seen them faces
when i'm like well you can't be do it
once you barking for like seven years
you gotta just
not just quit or just or just like
don't quit comedy but quit barking at
least and like how do you get out of
that life because people get stuck
i don't know i don't yeah i don't know
what it is but it's it stinks for sure
cause i remember
i heard the story you said about dan st
jermaine where the guy was oh yeah
for 10 more minutes and you'll get on
stage he's like nah yeah
well dan's a masochist man i mean that's
like there's a sickness to that where
you're like
he was that close to getting the spot
especially early on when you do anything
for a spot and he was like nah i'm good
and we're like
dude we're doing open mics you know